they lie about everything they lie about
everything and they obfuscate about
everything here's gay pete and gay pete
uh he feels that biden's doing pretty
good americans feel gas prices just
about more than anything else we're
seeing five dollars a gallon approaching
five dollars a gallon across the country
right now as we head into the summer
vacation season uh
earlier this year the president tapped
the strategic petroleum reserves that
hasn't made any difference at all was
that a failure
well look i i don't think it's correct
to say it hasn't made any difference at
all this is an action that helped to
stabilize global oil prices uh the
action the president took around ethanol
introducing additional flexibility there
that's having an effect on prices in the
midwest but we also know that the price
of gasoline is is not set by a dial in
the oval office
he's just nothing gay pete is just a
suit he's just a suit with talking point
that's all he is
first off gas prices have doubled
doubled since joe biden took office when
he kept calling this thing putin's price
hike we've covered this many times gas
was already up over a dollar a gallon
before in the year before the russian
invasion of ukraine so anytime anything
goes well they want credit for it but
when things go not well well
you know joe biden doesn't have a dial
he can't do anything but the craziness
from these people and i guess that
really is the theme of the show today is
is sort of like
after i spent you know 45 minutes with
the with probably the sanest guy in
america uh ron desantis and just like
honest clear policies just like
the collection
of just like insanity all over the place
uh is just it's so it's just so freaking
obvious right now and it's absolutely
everywhere